GameStop used to be the go-to place to
get cheap used games over the last
decade Game Stop used to pull hundreds
and billion dollars in revenue every
single year during its peak but over the
last couple of years
game shop has had less and less traffic
in sales last year they actually lost
over half a billion dollars so what
happened to gamestop and will they be
able to recover make sure stick around
till the end to find out welcome to
Horizonte games up actually started off
as Babbage's which is a tuckson Arizona
based software retailer founded in 1984
it was founded by James McCurry and Gary
Crewson who were actually Harvard
Business School classmates they decide
to name the company after their famous
inventor and mathematician Charles
Babbage's they established her first
store in Dallas North Park Center with
help from her early investor lost parent
the company was mainly focused on video
game sales and Atari 2600 which
absolutely dominate a market at the time
they also started offering in tender
games in 1987 and went public in 1988 by
1991 video game sales constituted for up
to two-thirds of Babbage's total sales
in 1994 they murdered software cetera
who was a Minnesota based retailer who
specialized in personal computing
software together they form a new Star
retail group with Gary Kristina's
president and James McCurry as chairman
but Gary Kuzon soon resigned in February
of 1995 the starters own cosmetics
company but soon the company fell into
disaster as in September they were not
able to secure credit in order to buy
enough inventory for the holiday season
as a result they had no choice but to
file for chapter 11 bankruptcy
Leonard rejuve it to buy the assets of
nearest are for fifty eight point five
million dollars he was the chairman and
principal stockholder of Barnes & Noble
Electronics Boutique there was also
another bid but that bidders declined as
Rogers bid would have keep open 100 more
stores but unfortunately overall 200
Riccio stores were forced to be closed
after purchasing neo star he dissolved
most of the holding company and created
a new holding company Babbage's etc
along with this he appointed in new
leadership positions in 1999 he launched
the GameStop brand which included 30
stars of strip malls he also launched
gamestop calm where consumers would buy
video games online
he also rates for heavy promotion of
games.com in Babbage's and South Korea
severance doors in October of 1999
Barnes & Noble bought Baptist etc for
$250 since Brazil was also principal
shareholder and chairman of the company
dad to play a special committee in order
to close the deal while a boarding bias
Barnes and Noble also ended up buying
Foucault a Minnesota based video game
retailer from 160 million dollars they
renamed all of these stories games table
and also bought Game Informer which was
a video game magazine Game Stop went
public in February of 2008 to bombard
novo retain majority control they owned
67% of auxin t-shirts and 95% of voting
shares the retained control of Game Stop
on 2 October of 2004 at this point they
distributed 59% of Game Stop to
stockholders of Barnes and Noble
this made gamestop an official
independent company and this initiated
the golden years of games up as they
went on an acquisition spree the court
EVP games in 2005 for one point four
four billion dollars this allowed them
to expand their operations in Canada
Europe Australia and New Zealand in 2007
there acquired by a video game from
blockbuster for an undisclosed amount
this custom seventy more video game
stores in southeastern United States
they also acquired free record shops
Norwegian stores in April of 2008
discontent 40 and more stores which
converted the video game shops at this
point he had a little bit of leadership
restructuring Daniel de Matteo replaced
Richard Fontaine as CEO and Home Depot
vice-president Paul Raines replaced
Daniels old position of CEO in June 2010
earless time period game stops digital
revenue
really grow as the first party services
were played that prominent at this time
in 2011 they got 100 million dollars in
revenue from this and then 2012 they got
over 600 million dollars in revenue from
this service they continued with their
acquisitions by buying congregates long
lapse impulse buy my product simply Mac
Spring mobile 163 Radio Shack locations
and 507 AT&T store chains at this point
they were doing really well in
diversifying the revenue streams outside
of this video game sales and today these
assets are what can save GameStop but
over the last couple of years they have
been on a decline as I have a dying
business model they have two major
issues the first of which is the rise of
digital downloads and game streaming
services and these are first party
services that are very reliable so they
are completely making physical copies of
games almost obsolete in the last
quarter of 2018 35% of games of revenue
came from physical copies of games being
sold so this is not good news for game
stock and decreasing revenue on finger
copies of games being sold it's not the
only effect that digital games has had
on gamestop the rise of digital
downloads has left and there being less
physical copies being the in circulation
overall as a result this also trials are
used game sales as well in the last
quarter of 2018 there's a counter for at
90% of the revenue this is also a major
loss for Game Stop and the second major
issue for Game Stop is that most
reserved stores are located in malls and
all malls are facing so attracting foot
traffic as Amazon is pointing up
tough competition even the biggest in
mall stores like Sears JC Penney and
Macy's are having trouble so it's no
wonder that Game Stop would also receive
less traffic recently Game Stop as part
of the Amazon offering Amazon cash for
used games but this hasn't meaningfully
improved their pre-owned sales right now
yeah 5800 brick-and-mortar stores with
the dying business model so it's very
hard for them to turn
and this is one of those unique
scenarios where it's not completely the
company's fault even if they were to
emphasize more on the original downloads
this really wouldn't help as our first
party services that people would no
doubt for her and this has left games
off in a really sticky situation
GameStop really put an effort to try a
diversified in stores beyond video game
sales the stars align gaming accessories
headsets pop culture collectibles and
comic books
they bought think geek in 2015 who is a
pop culture products retailer on top of
all of this they really emphasized on
selling digital downloads in last
quarter of 2018 each of these additions
grew by double-digit numbers but the
issue is that all of this combined is
less than 20% of game stops revenue
furthermore long-term growth isn't very
unpredictable for these growth of
accessories is heavily dependent on
success of popular games this is because
most of the accessories are based on
these games like for tonight which is
actually on its last leg right now and
the problem with digital revenue is that
it is easier to buy off of the first
party website and directly download it
onto your console instead of dealing
with serial numbers and all of the
hassle especially when it's the same
price in most cases plus there's also
competition from Amazon Walmart and Best
Buy and so on in this division as a
result Game Stop will have to offer
discounts and deals in order to attract
customers while traditional downloads as
a result Game Stop is having a lot of
trouble trying to diversify themselves
but from Gabe's point of view they have
had several internal issues over the
past couple of years they haven't even
had a permanent CEO for several years
unfortunately they'll all see you at
Adam cancer the new CEO resigned in just
three months for unknown personal
reasons despite a lack of strong
leadership games app has made some good
choices over the past couple years
for example they recently sold spring
mobile which included 1380 80 stores for
700 million dollars they can use all
this cash to pay off their 471 million
dollars in long-term debt that they have
and they can invest the rest of their
money in their digital storefronts
making themselves unique and is
when some sort of way and with the
appointment of a long-term CEO they can
a much clearer view of the future which
is a stronger emphasis on e-commerce
platforms right now they have a couple
of options moving forward they can
reduce difference and continue a
sell-off long video game related
businesses invest all this money into
your core business
all they can do the exact opposite by
closing all their stores and investing
all that money into more assets than
becoming a holding company but I think
most of us to prefer they take their
first rap game top has been on decline
her last couple of years but they are
not too far gone yet with the right
choices
they're definitely revival and
sustainable going into the future and
there is still hope in the end games
office a nostalgic company for many of
us but unfortunately they fall into some
trouble
as the digital world is starting to take
over fortunately in many liquefiable
assets and with that new leader and
purpose they can definitely turn things
around but will the uses are katrina
wisely or false or demise
just like blockbuster only time will
tell but that's all I have for you guys
on gamestop
makes a comment down below what
companies you'd like me to cover next
also if it's like smooth stuff like and
consider subscribing
just like this one but to learn I'm
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]